what's going on people we're gonna watch
ourselves some peacemaker one by seven
today
be peaceful by hitting that like button
be vigilant by subscribing and clicking
that bell to get notified when our
reaction for the next peacemaker is up
full length watch along so you sync up
with the time code with us on peacemaker
over at our patreon page we come with
superjet to dab and check out everything
over there lastly nikki tim's boys at
prepper for helping us edit down these
highlights where do you see my
backstory
use rock and roll forever and tongue
case hot babes and smoke pot all day
yeah
yeah
hey
me he had me to do that
right here let's go let your money talk
come on look at that mullis no kicking
no biting no grabbing
[Applause]
wow that is
sick don't be a [ __ ] get in there and
hate it
who needs [ __ ] fighting disturbing come
on
you hit like a girl they had them bare
knuckle box
oh that is
messed up
keith it caused him some brain trauma
dumb [ __ ] you killed your brother oh you
[ __ ] you made the fight and made
money off of it
that is so disturbing
[Music]
what a transition i now understand this
intro
the subtle tragedy of it yeah she
probably planted that diary in my
trailer i know i couldn't trust these
people
what the [ __ ] judo master judo message
oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] it can't worry about it now
got all the peacemaker helmets
programmed in these ones at the police
station they must have been confiscated
yesterday
but these ones that's got to be
christmas god damn it harry is fake of
course it's a fake
i was gonna write a diary wouldn't get
diary of your [ __ ] journal
vigilante and me might as well get this
done before they find us what done
kill this [ __ ] cow we are cool
no
a cow
maybe it's alien cow
you did it didn't you waller sent you
here for this express purpose did what
planted a diary in peacemaker's trailer
yes wow i don't want to be here no more
so i'm leaving well then why the [ __ ]
did you even come because i lost my job
and my mother offered me this one mother
yes oh it's all coming out holy [ __ ]
your mother is amanda waller hey you
need to get out of here
she's waller's daughter yeah i know oh
no
oh damn it
how have you not seen boondock scenes
it's a classic visual acting jesus
you're always after me like guitars
i love it
do your worst judo master are you guys
being a little nonchalant about all this
economos are you insinuating there is a
wrong time and a right time to rock
i feel like economos is going to die
yeah
now that you've said that i can feel it
they're on 395 north about past the exit
i've got eyes
[Music]
this nazi should not be so cool
why do i want an action figure
[Music]
i'm not ready for it someone's going to
take the ball
[Music]
no no no
yeah oh [ __ ]
will you do it what i should have done
long ago
oh buddy
oh
my god
that's it man we gotta go come on get up
as long as eagley makes it out man
[Music]
[Applause]
there's no wrong time
oh [ __ ]
[Music]
oh [ __ ] oh wow
you left your keys in the car what i was
rushing
an [ __ ] man you're an [ __ ] so what
do you want to do tonight you want to go
to the club
that's what's up
damn
oh damn open up
he's running like a spaz let's go
what animals it attached to
good call
[ __ ] raccoons are hardcore man
[Laughter]
no he's got a concussion
how do you know about the cow
nothing you can do will make me
you could have just joined us
[Music]
yeah murm's officially gone you murdered
him
the alternative was what
without him his outfit will have no
chance of stopping us two clowns and
costumes and a couple of rejects two
clowns at costumes rejects sounds like
the devil's re-checks
he did
oh
oh
oh that's really sad
dang dog [ __ ] oh you gotta be [ __ ]
kidding me right now
wow
[Music]
i love hotel fights
dumb [ __ ]
[Music]
get them everywhere jeez that was a
better fight than when peacemaker fought
judo mastermind
[Music]
stop
[Laughter]
how do it find you guys anyway he put a
gps tracking device in peacemaker's
helmet
what
oh no
i didn't know i thought they were
expensive
no
oh i got a piece of [ __ ] bat no
eagley get back in the car john can you
get him in the car sure
no babysitting eagerly better not i
swear to god get in the car oh jesus
he's not listening get back in the car
and crinkle a bag or something i'll
think you have chips
oh my gosh jeez
yum yum
[Laughter]
peacemaker running from nuts oh
my camerawork is so physical in this
episode what are you doing there here
why the [ __ ] are your pants all the way
down
my clothes are touching my butt
live eagly please
ah
i'll kill you [ __ ] you think so
i knew you was unclean when you were
born when you killed your brother i knew
when you shaved your body like a woman
oh
and now boys
[Music]
[Laughter]
i'm a piece of [ __ ] for listening to you
for all those years i'm a piece of [ __ ]
for not killing you in your sleep
like a girl
with a cougar no less i knew you
couldn't do it you [ __ ] cause i
control you whether or not i kill you
you'll never be able to get the [ __ ]
away oh
that's what i'm talking about it's like
the more
messed up version of civil war
oh wow
i'm not supposed to be here that's why i
was packing up i just want to do
whatever job i need to retelling right
from wrong ain't advanced calculus
because you're good at the job
and because we need every hand on deck
to try to go kill this cow
it's impossible we couldn't even get
there in time is this cow like a starrow
level kind of guy it's gotta be
hey john
pause oh my god is there a chance
there's gotta be a chance don't tease me
i swear to god what's going on dr
hurwitz kindly stitched up eagerly and
vigilante's being a total freak dude
they saw us peacemaker and i were wanted
i never should have left him in my
father's garage for four years when i
went to prison i should have found
somebody better to take care of him like
an ugly girl who was desperate for love
would have done anything i wanted when i
was locked up and you know i could just
broke up with her the moment i got out
and i was a bad friend eagerly the only
one besides keith that never loved me
for real
please god don't do anything you want
just
[Music]
keep
[Music]
[Music]
you know you're so happy to see me today
wrap his wings around me and hug me
an eagle hugged you oh yeah yeah i call
him [ __ ] on that you don't want to
believe in miracles that's on you
[Music]
take that selfie
take it
miracles
babe i just saw an eagle hug a humor
everything going on
how do we do this without mern we have
someone else that we can trust to lead
us me
now
[Music]
oh
you got this hard cord
they'll do what they can to move the cow
out before we get there
according to what adds and i overheard
teleportation
go in there and we kick ass like butch
cassidy and the sundance kid they get
slaughtered at the end of that film
freeze frame we hear a bunch of bullets
that doesn't mean they died yes it does
i don't think so i think they jumped
over those bullets right after that
freeze frame just like the devil's
rejects
i'm in
[Music]
hell yeah hashtag me too
[Music]
yeah
[ __ ] yeah
that's a big baby cow
that's not like area 51 [ __ ] right there
starship troopers yes
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
where's judo master i guess he's back at
the hotel
just left him there
let's suppose credit's going to be more
prayers that's as good a guesses
or
something with vigilante in the ribbon
at the
vet place
cleanliness is next to godliness
and god knows
i'm close to him blood that's what you
want to see
if you're not seeing any blood you're
not scrubbing hard enough
start at the bottom slap your way up
keep going a little higher
swing the hips
when you're drying especially it's
important to swing your hips
and we're finished now thank you very
much thank you for attending
[Laughter]
uh
holy moses as well
wild and emotional
show
eagerly lives eagerly he glue lives
oh man made it no no previews oh the car
trailer reactors ain't watching trails
it's weird watching a show that you know
is not gonna get golden globe
nominations but [ __ ]
yeah
good call it's one of those shows right
yeah it's so good it's so good like it
just keeps getting better and maintains
the humor
like it's sometimes i think like okay
this is gonna be the episode where we're
like just serious this is the serious
intense one and while there there's so
much you know intensity in this one like
this one like brought me to tears i was
on the edge of my seat i was freaking
laughing and i was like man this is like
the whole package right here i'm really
digging it so much and john cena's
performance is so strong
i i just can't i i don't know why i
never
suspected this level of acting talent
the guy has i guess it really just
depends on the right director or
character whatever or maybe he's always
been this talented and i just had no
clue because he is phenomenal here man
um
pushed to the lengths i think it's
interesting how they started off with
the brother death or you explain what
happened with keith
and you know like the way they did those
flashbacks before those little glimpses
of the traumatic hauntings of that that
like core memory for
chris
it constantly seemed like okay maybe
there's like rough housing or messing
around and then by an accident he he
killed him like something purely
unintentional where he he was where
chris was out of line as a kid and then
you see this flashback and you're like
dude yeah this guy freaking does auggie
deserves to die this guy is the worst he
already was the worst and then he just
got worse than the worst
in this moment like you see him placing
the bets
and he's
exploiting his children's playtime and
put pitting them against each other and
then still walks out blaming chris for
what happened
uh it is so absurd and
like just horrifying absolutely
horrifying
and this whole time you've been seeing
these flashbacks you're like oh the
weight of keith
that his death falls on chris's
shoulders
because he feels personally responsible
for it and the way they've made this arc
where after eagerly his best friend it
looks like he's been killed
by his own
dad this comes out he starts unleashing
his rage everything underneath the
surface and he's you know just pouring
it all on him like it was your fault
it's your response it was it's his fault
and it is like a it really did feel like
civil war
you know he's got like an iron man like
red suit yeah helmet off he's beating
him he's on top of him the american
symbol is on top you know ready to kill
him and said that just follow through
with someone actually dying
um it was really uh it was really
fascinating and then yeah of course when
he kills him he's going to be brought to
tears because it's still his father and
he still loved him
in spite of all this
meanwhile red dragon be looking like the
coolest mofo
ever
wow you know he's pretty he's got like
this uh
like 90s 2000s like cheese about and it
feels intentional because
he's a former
he's the right words hero but the former
he's a former uh costumed super person
yeah yeah so it feels like appropriate
to have it feel like it's from an
earlier era yes it is yeah absolutely
and i loved it i loved the way they
handled that
that arc there
is strong stuff yeah and it was like the
right size because you know the white
dragon suit has these like blasts and
this like rocket ability built in but
it's not so much
that you can't believe that chris might
have a chance against him uh and yeah
like this episode like you said it was
firing on all cylinders and it did
everything the show does
across the board really well all in one
package which was the most impressive to
me like you said you laugh you cry you
know you're you're tense you're you're
having fun and sometimes all those
things are having are happening at the
same time
and uh yeah i think it really is credit
to the i wonder if maybe it's just
because
dwayne johnson has such
a sort of mold
in being the wrestler turned actor etc
etc that i almost sometimes wonder if
that contributes to the sort of everyone
being surprised when john cena has the
chops because i feel like at this point
you could argue that john cena is maybe
a better emotional actor than dwayne
johnson is in certain cases in certain
varieties of scenes
and i love like none of this would work
if that wasn't true or it wouldn't work
as well as it does if that wasn't true
uh because yeah this guy who is such a
buffoon and such a joke in certain ways
is is also really really tortured in a
way that's very tangible and in a way
that i just loved what they were able to
do with this episode because so much
plot happened but also i feel like we
got the most amount of emotional
resonance we've had so far it's probably
my favorite episode of the season up to
this point uh for for all those reasons
and yeah even though you know we've only
spent one
season with these characters as of now
and even though auggie is you know a
prominent character he's not like the
most prominent character and there are
ways in which i could imagine this
feeling like oh damn you know they
already killed him off but this felt
very
you know it felt like
the story of how this guy died
not just a story about how he could have
died you know like the the showdown
between them felt so visceral and so
personal and that
you know is most realized between auggie
and chris but it's throughout the
episode with a lot of characters i mean
i feel like these intense sort of
singular interpersonal moments really
pinned the episode together and you see
that with uh obviously chris and auggie
but also with adebayo and and
harcourt
and even i mean
even uh uh uh
that moment shared
unknowingly between her and chris you
know as as chris is like crying over
eagerly and praying to god like
yeah there's so many uh really great
character beats amid all the action and
the chaos
well this was the revelatory
episode where you see arcs this is where
the arcs come full circle harcourt is
you know the way she's spewing her
blurred lines of what lives matter and
what lives down when she's arguing
without a bio
and you're starting to see that like you
know she really does care about chris
she's spouting stuff like he was your
friend
you know also her saying he's my friend
too
and then at a bio
uh getting to see some of when she's
getting defensive you're like oh there's
some of the wallers coming out of her in
this moment you know where she's trying
to justify her actions or like here's
why you shouldn't get on my ass about
this like this this choice made sense at
the time clearly you know um
i know the actress's name but her
um that her performance was indicating
that this is clearly a defense mechanism
and not today like this is what she
really thinks whereas like with waller
it really seems like waller thinks that
way yeah or her she doesn't agree with
her mom
and she's just trying to please so
you know i think her performance is so
strong so you have this like exploration
and and
you know even with it but by the end of
that a bio would realize where she
belongs she like chooses to stay on this
one she has
totally out where she can just go home
but she's choosing to stay on this
mission for something bigger than a job
and uh same thing with harcourt
elevating to the position of leader mirn
you really see his true intent here of
like you
already revealed it but clearly willing
to die and be like you guys carry on the
mission seemed like you communicated
something like kind of telepathically or
some [ __ ] to harcourt when uh when when
harcourt was slowing the butterfly in
her hand yeah and
um
not something vigilante's vigilante yeah
he was proven right
for chris you know even very
symbolically with the peacemaker helmet
like literally this whole show has
started off with peacemaker here's who
he is here's who you think he is now
let's strip away who's the man
underneath the mask now you get to this
episode where literally the mask is
removed yeah this this this this
physical thing that is so connected so
tethered to
you know
his dad he literally gets the helmets
from his father
and
now that's removed that's gone now
and i think that's such an interesting
choice and that's such a key keystone
part of the peacemaker yeah it costs too
many
peacemaker
but it's a but it's a rich choice yeah
yeah and economos uh even he like he's
just a guy behind the computer now he
just gets out in the field and gets
dirty gotta take out all the nazis you
know it was a really rewarding moment
quite uh
yeah i like the relationship that's more
with hardcore how to buy and hardcore is
becoming more sensitive she even makes a
choice with
the
that's
because normally you saw an episode
where she did just off an innocent
person because our identities were
compromised and now here she decides not
to and so as you're seeing all these
like great arcs in here and then setting
up for like the big mission now just
about with episode 8 stick
this episode's happening yeah well
episode 8 is stick the landing
ultimately and i i feel like it will it
you see with the with the big creature
at the end you're like okay this is
feeling more like the suicide squad
spin-off now yeah yeah yeah before
you're like okay you got a team of
misfits here who don't really know how
to work together the best
and now they they're they're choosing
to stay together
in spite of all the odds being stacked
against them against an
alien threat
and this alien that they gotta kill is
massive yeah and they got very well
protected and they got a horde of these
beings so they gotta take care of two
and yeah
you're like okay i see some of the more
there's the similarities now more like
this now now this has been like the
suicide squad spin-off yeah which is
good it was fine you know i never i
never really thought about it uh in that
regard and i i don't mind it at all and
[ __ ] judo master john talk about judo
master was badass and i mean i love the
almost comic strip quality judo master
has had throughout this series minus the
introduction you know we meet him with
goth so he's a henchman and that makes
sense but from here it's like they just
kind of have to keep him contained and i
agree that that fight scene in the hotel
room was i think one of the standouts
for the season and i think it did
actually outstrip the one between him
and chris because in the 2000s we were
getting like a lot of
like those hotel fight scenes well yeah
especially
like jason bourne movies and stuff yeah
yeah yeah yeah well since we got a fight
scene like that we're just like oh it's
brutal they're using the items around
them they're thrashing into stuff
anytime someone like breaks a sink or a
toilet yeah like oh yeah this is a nasty
like rough and tumble fight scene and
and you know throughout
it's especially apparent in the judo
master scenes even outside the
convenience store where he whips those
two guys ass is like the camera work in
this episode was so visceral and you'd
have things it's like
shots where it feels like the camera is
right in the action or or gets you know
hit with you know debris and stuff like
that and yeah it's like it's so
so physical and so pulpy and so violent
but in a very in a way that doesn't
break the fun like again that's one of
the charms of james gunn is like it is
bone crunching and gross in certain
respects or or just cringe-worthy in
certain respects but also uh is just so
cool and i love how like out of all
these characters that have been so
fleshed out judo master has remained a
complete constant every time we have
seen he's got his snacks
he doesn't say much he's got an attitude
and he'll kick your ass and that's
that's it that's that character and i
wouldn't be surprised if he shows up one
more time before the season's over or or
maybe in like the the maybe like some
kind of weasel style stinger
you know at the end of the finale
episode now saving the best part for
last
equally eagley
holy balls man since the first episode
i've been like that eagle's gonna die
isn't it i'm holding on
so worried and then this episode
made me go
shh like i when i was first thinking i
feel like economos was gonna die
my real thought
was
i'm feeling eagle's gonna die but i
don't to put it out there
so you sacrificed economists
he'll take anyone before he could
and then it just started seeming like
they were really hinting towards it you
know clearly they're not afraid to kill
off animals uh and [ __ ] like this and
james gunn's not afraid to kill off
animals in his projects
so and in his private life
yeah i was surprised they didn't do
anything to the raccoons when they found
the helmet dude i thought they were
gonna shoot the racket yeah i thought
they were gonna make it i i i appreciate
the restraint on those things but yeah
it's clever how they how it's all tied
in it's neat because even though they
swap out directors like brad anderson
mr andrew brad anderson directed this
episode but james gunn wrote every one
of them
so it's cool when you could see how
connected all these things are like
establishing in the last episode when
equally in the field and like taking out
some some of them cops so it's like okay
yeah this isn't some
random thing like if there was just
introducing this episode it'd be like
what the [ __ ] yeah like we were doing
this before you know and so like you're
just putting an excuse here to get him
in this this perilous situation
so yeah you have that where he's like
taking out some of the kkk kind of guys
i think they're gonna have like a truck
hit him or something like that when he's
just out on the road yeah yeah he's like
trying to work you're just gonna shoot
him yeah just they they really the way
they played with the audience they they
played it like a horror game we have
sharing him in this guy like they're
following him and hold on we're
uploading something simultaneously can
you just tap that john yeah thanks um
yeah so i thought that they were uh
they're gonna kill him off but then
that scene when he is in the vet is like
that's that's so encompassing of
everything of what makes this show so
good you have the chris character he's
saying [ __ ] sincerely and it's funny but
then you're also crying
uh at least i was i was really yeah i
was [ __ ] it was get into me and then
and then to have that full circle moment
where
she sees it like i like the use of the
flashback that was really good
yes
sometimes
i was in movies like we don't need the
flashback but the use of the flashback
helped enhance the humor it was moving
in this like angelic way yeah
well yeah cause it's not for exposition
no no yeah yeah it's almost an
exposition free flashback in a sense i
mean it does function to remind you but
yeah no it felt like a cinematic choice
of a flashback um eagley man he's my man
hugging an eagle i hope this isn't some
misleading words first episode
first moment
yeah
as it stands man this is uh this is
truly awesome what a way to kick off
2022 with that show yeah that's enough
and um
i feel like it's a pretty appreciated
gem it's just not available in some
countries right now so that's why yeah
yeah but they say it's uh it's hbo's
number one show right now so
you know what else they got euphoria i'm
sorry z4 he's the number one oh yeah
like foreign number one
maybe it'll take the crown back once
peacemaker finishes up next week i was
surprised to hear that too because how
did you hear that i like it like this
past week people were talking about it
because at first it was creating out
euphoria a couple of weeks ago i was
seeing not from like the reputable
sources but i was seeing like youtube
videos about like ah man peacemakers
failing because of wokeness and then
like
like a week later then i started seeing
like other places like variety being
like peacemakers like
the hot top rated show maybe maybe it's
that i don't know if it's like a
difference in like how people rated it
versus viewership but it was pitched as
being their top show right now it was
pitched as being
more views than boba fett yeah i think
that changed when a certain character
appeared poof
but it's been doing really really well
from what i understand i mean euphoria
is a juggernaut yeah but this maybe has
the edge because it's the first season i
don't know all right guys
well thank you so much for being here
what did you think about this episode
leave your thoughts down below you can
subscribe leave a like and uh last but
not least do a patreon
anissa oliva anisa
[Music]
you know what screw jokes you've been
amazing
you're you're just like
a total gem you ask for nothing from us
you've been so loyal to us for so long
so supportive and you've also gone
way above and beyond for us and
more ways i've lost
sincerely i've lost so much track
of just how far you've gone above and
beyond for us
so
just know you're always in my mind and
heart you matter so much to me
and
you're just one of the coolest
[ __ ] i've ever met
it's a good way to put that you are
super cool and we do not deserve your
love yeah you're you're
you're thebomb.com
and uh i love you and it is one of my
life's goals to meet you one day in
person talking on the phone talking
various video chat yeah
yeah one day in person it'll happen
thank you so much for remaining loyal to
us this entire time
you rock
[Music]
you